it's still warm in the dining room for
now
lunch is being served in the children's
home in layover in Western Moldova but
director Catalina postica is worried
about the winter
energy and food prices are rising and
she fears for the children's well-being
it's a similar situation across the
country
modabus pro-european Administration is a
thorn in moscow's side so Russia is
wielding its most effective weapon gas
Russia controls the Breakaway region of
transnistria where gas is used to
produce electricity
normally this covers two-thirds of
moldova's power needs
demand is high because the entire
country uses electric heating even buses
are electric now Russia has cut gas
exports claiming that Moldova has failed
to make payments
gas problems
has raised this issue of stop supplying
because of not payment in term
now since August last year then
pro-european government is in office we
have paid absolutely absolutely all
uh in in in in time or I will be
the energy crisis is a threat to
moldova's existence
that's one reason why the president of
the European commission rushed to the
moldovan capital kishinau to promise Aid
to the country
after all Moldova is now an EU candidate
winter is just around the corner and it
can be long and cold in layover
people here are already spending over
half their income just on energy
foreign
it seems way too high
I took out a bank loan and bought wood
this month all of my income is going
towards bills and the loan
things are hard everywhere we'll survive
but I'd hoped it would be easier
the situation is especially dire for the
most vulnerable
families The Children Here were raised
in lower income families and weren't
provided the care they needed
some have been victims of violence or
abuse
our job is to protect them and steer
them down the right path
for many here it's the first place where
they feel safe and secure
so much better here
I get regular meals and it's warm
I don't have much at home but I do here
it's way different here
I feel like I'm part of the family
the director is used to getting by in a
shoestring budget but the Warren
neighboring Ukraine has made things much
worse
a large share of their budget is now
going to energy costs
we've been using electric heaters in the
children's rooms
and here in the laundry room we wash
their clothes
electricity prices have shot up so much
since the summer
by now we already have a deficit
equivalent to two months of our budget
leova's government wants to keep finding
the children's home but they're also
worried
the moment
right now expenses have about doubled
we're really doing everything we
possibly can
um
we don't want the children to be forced
to live in the cold
it can take a long time to find Foster
families for the children here Catalina
postica wants to make sure they have a
warm place to call home in the meantime
we can only hope that we find solutions
to get the high prices under control
this year
long way in coming